petit jour les champs-elysées avait été
mis à sac d'où une reprise en main du
maintien de l'ordre par le ministre de
l'intérieur le premier ministre et son
hôte le président de la république avec
un certain succès puisque les
manifestations étaient plutôt calmes
écoutez valérie pécresse la présidente
du conseil régional d'île de france
elle s'en féliciter ce matin même si
elle estime que ce progrès est encore à
confirmer
il ya visiblement eu un changement de
doctrine dans dans l'utilisation de nos
forces pour le maintien de l'ordre et ça
on ne peut que le saluer mais j'ai envie
de dire la sécurité ce n'est pas qu'un
samedi sur deux alors sauf que il y a
évidemment cet incident qui aurait pu
être un drame et qui fait beaucoup de
bruit
ça s'est passé à nice il y avait une
manifestation non autorisée à laquelle
participait une femme de 73 ans qui a
été blessé pas directement par la police
mais sont utiles en trébuchant contre un
élément de mobilier urbain alors que les
forces de l'ordre étaient en train de
disperser cette manifestation non
autorisée et emmanuel macron le prochain
à un public il assume le l'action de ces
forces de sécurité dans un entretien au
journal nice matin il dit quand on est
fragile qu'on peut se faire bousculer on
ne se rend pas dans des lieux qui sont
définies comme interdit et on ne se met
pas dans des situations comme celle-ci
je lui souhaite dit elle à cette femme
blessés un prompt rétablissement et
peut-être une forme de sagesse
et comme souvent quant à emmanuel macron
parle
marlène schiappa applaudi des deux mains
je crois que ce qu'a dit président de la
république c'est un message de bon sens
je crois que lorsqu'on voit les
violences qu'on voit depuis le 20
novembre et particulièrement ces
dernières semaines
en marge de ces manifestations
effectivement quand on est dans une
situation de fragilité
le bon sens voudrait qu'on n'aille pas
dans ces manifestations qui sont des
formes de mise en danger potentielle
maxis bail
on a le sentiment que le pouvoir assume
le risque de 2,2 qu'il ya un blessé dans
ses manifestations
ben c'est toujours un risque on
manifeste effectivement il peut y avoir
des blessés je sais pas si cette dame de
74 73 73 ans a besoin de ça j'ai par
contre elle a du courage de manifester à
son âge
ce soit une bonne chose qu'elle
manifestations n'y a pas d'âge pour
manifester donc il faut arrêter de voilà
de bonnes ça très personnellement mais
j'étais à paris hier au sacré coeur à la
fin de la manifestation d'aidé gilet
jaune je suis allé voir il y avait une
très bonne ambiance étaient autorisés à
c'était autorisé il ya une très bonne
ambiance
non j'étais pas sur les champs-elysées
il y avait même des touristes qui
faisaient des selles fille d'un gilet
jaune y avait une très bonne ambiance
c'est à dire que cette fois ci les pas
les black blocks voilà et donc il y
avait des gilet jaune qui manifestait de
manière tout à fait légale avec il ya eu
des interactions avec la police qui
était très aimable donc je dirais qu'il
faut aussi sortir des images et de
l'exagération
il faut voir que quand on sent les
casseurs des gilet jaune est bas les
choses se passent plutôt bien
donc après est-ce qu'il faut répéter ça
est-ce qu'il faut effectivement
interdire de manifester sur les champs
elysées pourquoi pas tant qu'on laisse
un john marge d'expressions de
manifester moi je trouve qu'il n'ya
aucun problème
encore une fois il à force il hier soir
s'est très bien passé avant-hier soir
s'est très bien passé ou sacré coeur
c'est une bonne leçon je pense attirer
40 je vous ai vu sursauter un oui devant
les propos de oui exactement ce qu avec
ces m'a dit qu'il en fallait du courage
pour manifester à 60 revers non mais
c'est bien de manifester c'est bien
exercer sa liberté politique moi je suis
en démocratie j'aime les manifestations
mais j'aime aussi le respect des règles
et quand la manifestation est interdite
ne vous laissez pas du courage de faire
quelque chose qui est interdit après
alors la question n'est pas c'était très
clair sur le terrain je sais pas vous
mais je n'étais pas sûr que les
interviews
oui enfin je sais pas si on est en train
de philosopher ce que je sais pas
comment ça s'est passé sur terre est
interdite
donc il faut respecter les lois sinon
plus le bordel voilà c'est ça la règle
faut respecter les règles du chef voilà
mais la question c'est est ce qu'on
risque d'aller se faire matraquer par la
police est facile de ce que vous dites
ça veut dire que c'est légitime qu'elle
entend né s'est pas fait matraquer par
la police lcl a trébuché sur un sur un
beau mobilier urbain on se demande même
pourquoi l aventure de cette femme et
dans les médias tout court
déjà ensuite effectivement quand trophée
du maintien de l'ordre
eh bien oui les riches y avoir des
blessés c'était ça la question au départ
je crois est ce qu'on fait le maintien
de l'ordre en dépit du fait qu'il peut y
avoir des blessés est bien fait répond
doit être oui même si pendant depuis
trop longtemps en fait l'état hésite
à faire du maintien d'ordre quand il ya
des blessés alors à cet égard ce qui
aurait été intéressant c'est de
réfléchir à cette question
en sortant du problème des gilet jaune
est à se demander si globalement est-ce
que c'était pas un problème que
précisément l'état n'ose plus faire des
blessés puisque cela l'a conduit à
reculer sur le maintien de l'ordre dans
tout un tas de territoire dont personne
ne parle
je vous rappelle par exemple que à viry
châtillon quand il ya des policiers qui
se sont fait brûler dans leur voiture
c'est parce que des dizaines de jeunes
sont arrivés pour avec l'intention de
les tuer et n'y a pas eu d'intervention
de la police parce qu'on sait en fait on
s'est dit à ce moment-là que si la
police intervenait sa tresse des
centaines de jeunes qui allaient venir
donc ça fait trop longtemps en fait que
la police ne peut plus intervenir pour
mille raisons que ce soit notamment dans
ces territoires perdus mais on apprend
aussi que c'est face à ces gels et jaune
parce que déclin qui se fait un bleu
la small à tout le monde tout le monde
monte au cocotier
ici on attendait ce que moi j'suis
désolé j'ai pas fini
j'ai pas fini la violence est légitime
elle l'avait de la police a le monopole
de la violence légitime ça veut pas dire
qu'elle est autorisée a blessé et a tué
qui elle veut naturellement ça veut dire
qu'il ya une présomption irréfragable du
fait que quand elles baisent quelqu'un
elle avait a priori des bonnes raisons
de le faire même si on doit évidemment
faire une enquête derrière pour
s'assurer que c'était le cas qu'elle
appelle utiliser des moyens trop
dangereux etc
et si en revanche quelqu'un un civil
blesse un policier ou blessent un autre
civil et à une présomption irréfragable
qui n'avait pas de bonnes raisons de le
faire
sauf évidemment si on trouve la légitime
défense etc oui je pense que je suis
assez d'accord avec certains points mais
je pense que vous mélangez plusieurs
aspects sincèrement ce qui se passe
place garibaldi n'a pas grand chose à
voir avec les incidents à ce qu'areva t
alis place garibaldi à nice chose à voir
avec ce qui se passe aux champs elysées
il ya une semaine par exemple là
effectivement le problème d'ailleurs que
pose cette séquence n'est pas l'action
des forces de l'ordre et personne ne le
dit pour ainsi dire un telle attestation
officielle ce qu'on a entendu sur nous a
présenté c'est la réaction du chef de
l'état dire qu'effectivement il ya une
intervention des forces de l'ordre
tout prouve que à la pâleur par sûrement
violente il ya un accident et après il
ya un commentaire du chef de l'état qui
rappelle furieusement pour les gens de
ma génération
le commentaire de robert
rouen 86 et après l'avoir de m cecchin
et que c'est un commentaire qu'on peut
juger ne trompe pas tout à fait à la
hauteur ou dans le rôle du chef de
l'état elle avait dit robert pandraud à
l'époque
après tout c'est clean avait dit que
dire n'était pas vraiment un manifestant
avait dit après qu'il ait été tué par
des voltigeurs lui-même est
effectivement une insuffisance médicale
parce qu'il était sous dialyse donc été
matraqué durement mais c'est pas
exactement ça qui a causé sa mort robert
pandraud qui était le ministre adjoint
de charles pasqua ne rentra sécurité
voilà avait dit je suis père de famille
s'il y avait un fils avec une dialyse
je ne serais pas allé faire le con
dehors c'était si vous voulez des propos
d'une violence juste après la mort d'un
jeune homme par rapport à la famille par
rapport à ce que ce que doit dire breton
de l'état qui est effective a été très
mal vécu à l'époque
emmanuel macron c'est beaucoup moins
violent mais sincèrement dans son rôle
de chef de l'état je trouve qu'il n'a
rien à gagner à tenir ce genre de propos
sur la forme c'est rang de sages et je
crois toujours à la sélection à
l'aménagement revient par ailleurs sur
ce que vous avez dit tout à l'heure que
moi mais je met met un peu mal à l'aise
malgré le fait donc c'est normal
d'ailleurs ce n'est pas d'accord et donc
faire sans fait que le fait
qu'effectivement tout le monde connaît
la ma phrase max weber qui est ressassé
depuis quatre mois
l'état le monopole de la violence
légitime d'accord mais ça veut pas dire
que tous deux ans de l'état de légitime
faut quand même faire très attention à
ce qu'ils vont dire et d'ailleurs la
pensée libérale que nous partageons les
uns les autres plus ou moins bien et
c'est justement de se méfier des
empiétements de l'état sur les libertés
individuelles et par ailleurs on a
beaucoup en son nom voilà est par
ailleurs enfin et cela juste un petit
notation on peut pas avoir cette
conversation aujourd'hui comme on
l'aurait eu il ya quatre mois c'est à
dire il ya quand même eu effectivement
de très nombreux blessés
et je ne dis pas que les par exemple que
les balles de l bd ne soit pas tiré de
manière légitime mais elles sont tirées
il ya quelques semaines on parlait déjà
de 10000 grenade a tiré des grenades en
dehors même de la bd les manifestants
mais la démarche agrément il ya quand
même pas mal de gens qui ont perdu un
etc et si vous voulez on peut pas faire
comme si la police était totalement
inhibé dans la répression du mouvement
social et le sujet que vous soulignez
sur les quartiers où ce qui se passe à
grenoble et c est à mon avis d'un autre
ordre après certains se posent la
question pourquoi il ya effectivement un
usage d'une répression policière peut
être légitime mais enfin en tout cas
sans une émission face au gilet jaune et
pourquoi on a l'impression sous réserve
d'en quête que dans certains quartiers
dans cette situation là par contre la
police est profondément inhibés alors
d'abord je n'ai jamais d'estimer les
âges de d'armes qui arrachent des mains
ou qui qui qui perce des yeux jamais
j'ai dit rien différente vous la
violence légitime mais pour autant d
ivoire d enquête pour s'assurer que la
police n'a pas outrepassé n'a pas
utilisé les armes trop violente pour le
maintien de notre cadeau auquel elle
devait procéder mais vous qu'on vous
comparez le cas ma liste coaching qui
est un jeune homme qui manifestait une
manifestation a priori autorisé et qui
se fait matraquer par des policiers
alors qu'il n'y avait aucune bonne
raison pour qu'il le fasse avec le cadre
d'annoncer ça fait cliché battu puis en
l'époque c'était une manifestation
interdite c'était des gens voir saint
michel
c'était effectivement et c'était
effectivement ce que ne faisait pas
partie des gens qui voulaient les mâles
et les voltigeurs ne savait pas sans
doute donc je pense était naze et de
situations mais il était seul il s'est
fait matraquer par toute une série de
policiers là c'est une dame qui est qui
a trébuché sur un élément de mobilier et
qui était dans un endroit où la
manifestation n'était pas autorisée
je crois qu'il est normal que les chefs
de l'état disent on ne manifeste pas
quand ce n'est pas autorisé ce créateur
a dit vous êtes très habile en tout cas
de cession sur nous la cathédrale mais
c'est quand même son rôle de le dire
vous êtes sur ce plateau et nos
internautes aussi c'est quand on leur
demandait est-ce que vous pensez que
emmanuel macron a eu raison de parler
comme il l'a fait et bien c'est très
exactement 50 50
non c'est pas un sondage ce sont vos
réactions
claude dit oui emmanuel macron a raison
car il faut parfois rappeler les choses
simplement
c'est une phrase qui pourrait adresser à
quiconque quel que soit son âge alors
que j'ai lu que nous dit toujours
moralisateur et méprisant macro n'aime
pas les français et je veux vous choisi
les pointages de plus tranché c'est
intéressant 27 internautes à une forme
de sagesse peut-être c'est pas c'est à
vous d'en juger
le commentaire l'odyssée débat parce
qu'on a 73 ans qu'on doit pas respecter
les lois
le baby no 10 cette pauvre dame était
pacifiste
c'est vrai qu'elle avait un drapeau en
ce sens il a clairement eu un usage
disproportionné de la force
brownie tôt personnellement je pense qu
amener des personnes fragiles et sur des
lieux où les violences sont possibles et
de l'inconscience florian les propos d'
emmanuel macron sont indignes de la
fonction présidentielle
bref vous êtes très partagés et vous
mathieu soupière quel est votre point de
vue je sais même pas si on est si
divisée ou partagée que cela en fait la
question c'est vraiment c'est bon il ya
une évolution de la dôle dans l'est dans
les méthodes de maintien de l'ordre
ben avec le risque qu'ils aient des
blessés et tant pis point
d'interrogation
non il ya en fait il ya un tâtonnement
en continu qui tient au fait que et je
trouve que ça relève d'une forme de
maturité démocratique nous nous
condamnons et les violences des
manifestants et de potentielles
violences policières en fait et on
voudrait trouver un cheminement qui
permettent de garantir et les libertés
publiques et une liberté publique
fondamentale qui est celle de manifester
et en même temps d'éviter des
débordements ou des violences bas et le
fait qu'on refuse tout à la fois des
violences de manifestants de casseurs et
des violences policières ne me paraît
pas en fait absurde
alors ensuite valérie pécresse disait
elle-même il ya des ajustements dans la
doctrine
dans la doctrine d'intervention des
forces de l'ordre et jérôme sainte-marie
faisait un parallèle avec la mort
dramatique de malik oussékine dans 86
qui avait conduit à ce que les forces de
l'ordre à l'époque revoit de façon
fondamentale en fait leurs méthodes
d'intervention à l'aise dans la réaction
du chef de l'état et son opportunité
absolument les événements absolument
mais à l'époque ce drame qui était une
bavure et qui avait coûté très cher
politiquement au gouvernement en place
avait avait ensuite débouché sur un
changement radical de philosophie
d'intervention des forces de l'ordre
là on voit bien qu'on se cherche on voit
bien qu'on se cherche et que tant qu'on
se cherchera on ne pourra pas être
satisfait certes on peut se réjouir que
ce week end ça n'est pas débordé alors
on peut évidemment exprimer toute sa
sympathie et sa solidarité avec la
manifestante qui a trébuché et qui a du
coup aujourd'hui un problème de santé
il semble que ses jours ne soient pas en
danger et malgré tout comme ils disaient
carnutes heures ça fait vingt-quatre
heures qu'on commente les images de
cette manifestante qui a chuté de façon
plus ou moins accidentelle bon et tout
on est muette c'est haram est donc
globalement ça n'a pas débordé et donc
ça on peut s'en réjouir
et dans le même temps pour que ça ne
déborde pas il a fallu mobiliser 60
mille forces de l'ordre ce qui
rapportait aux quarante mille
manifestants paraît quand même
relativement d iran par bon support
quand je demandais alors ma foi en tout
cas la mise en miroir de ces deux
chiffres
questionne et les huit mille
interventions ou neuf mille
interventions préventives interpellation
préventive pardon donc on voit bien que
il va falloir qu'on développe une
philosophie d'intervention qui soit
raccord avec les principes fondamentaux
que nous cherchons à défendre en
démocratie et je ferme cette partie du
débat si vous le voulez bien avec ce
propos pleins de sagesse de guillaume et
ça n'est pas moi guillaume qui nous dit
tout est sujet à polémiques quel que
soit l'auteur
oui c'est bien vrai sauf peut-être le
dernier sujet je vous annonçais dans le
sommaire le
ou un chinois xi jinping est en france
depuis hier il était en visite
officielle il était cet après midi à
l'arc de triomphe avec le président de
la république alors il ya évidemment
beaucoup de propos diplomatiques sur la
coopération fructueuse entre les deux
pays n'empêche que les chinois nous font
de plus en plus peur parce qu'ils sont
plus en plus puissants économiquement
enfin ils font pas peur à tout le monde
c'est pas vrai parce que par exemple il
ya didier guillaume le ministre de
l'agriculture lui il nous rappelle que
nous avons une arme secrète contre les
chinois